yeah this storm system ripped through a
170 Mile Stretch along the Mississippi
Delta covering the state of Mississippi
and Alabama I'm in Rolling Fork
Mississippi which is just about the
hardest hit town at least 12 people have
died here and it's easy to see why given
the scenes of utter Devastation this
place has been completely pulverized in
part if I just bring you over here you
can see the cleanup operation has
already begun that crane over there is
moving into clear an area which was once
the supermarket here not that you would
know earlier today two bodies were found
in the remains of that structure I've
been hearing all day Tales of death and
damage but also of survival
as day breaks in Rolling Fork
Mississippi there is no question of the
path This Tornado took
mounds of wood and corrugated iron
they're little resemblance to what once
stood here
a diner a motel and mobile trailers home
to the poorest people in this community
was blood running down my face and it
was raining Loretta has just been
discharged from hospital it's the first
time she's returned I heard something
like a a roaring train
and and I started back towards my
kitchen and Something Told Me Hit the
Floor
so I just hit the floor
and I started crawling
as I was crawling
I was praying to God and what hurt me so
people was uh calling for help
and I couldn't help
and some of them died and I couldn't
help them
amid the Lost Tales of Escape are
everywhere in Rolling Fork perhaps the
most miraculous of all at Chuck's Diner
nine people crammed into one half of
this walk-in refrigerator Tracy the
owner doesn't know how long they were
there for my daughter and my sister both
sent a text
urging us to get to a safe place someone
said cooler if that was me or one of the
ladies or who but we
rushed into the this unit here we rushed
into the cooler side of it there were
nine of us in all and my husband helped
got us all in there really quickly and
he went to close the door but the wind
kind of took the door from him
somehow he managed to get it back
and before he could fully close it he
said I see the sky
and that
and that just meant our roof was gone
200 mile per hour winds left little here
untouched
in the deeply religious Mississippi
Delta Evangelical Christian groups are
leading the relief effort
but there is no hiding the Deep racial
and economic divides here
one-fifth of the mostly black people in
Rolling Fork live below the poverty line
that's all I could get out of there
Irwin could only Salvage a suitcase from
what remains of his mobile home
everything just ripping off around you
and all you get is what you laying on I
don't know what it's going to take to
get this town ever back to what it was
the search and rescue operation is
continuing but this is most likely now a
recovery mission to find those who
against such a violent storm stood
little chance
people here received very little warning
of what was to come many describe
receiving a text alert on their phone
urging them to seek shelter immediately
but before they had chance the storm was
upon them and you may be able to see
behind me the skies darkening once more
you might be able to to hear the thunder
or even see the lightning and people
here are now worrying about the next
storm thunderstorm and hail warnings are
in place across this state with even the
potential for more tornadoes
particularly in the southern part of
Mississippi